[Music]
I'm in love with two men at the same
time and it's very difficult what's
Difficult about it for you cuz I love my
husband you don't hold on hold on you
don't and you have hurt him so that that
ship sale I don't want to leave my
husband but I don't want to break things
off with this other gentleman
[Music]
either what up what up what up this is
John with the Dr John delone show show
about your mental and emotional health
and your marriage and your kids all of
it so glad that you're with us on this
show we talk about everything talk about
um living with people who are hard to
live with we talk about finding love we
talk about man your mental health
whatever is going on in your life um I'm
here for you we'll sit with you and
we'll figure out what to do next if you
want to be on the show give me a buzz at
18448 uh 693 3291 it's 1844 693 3 3291
or go to John dooney.com
ask couple of housekeeping notes this is
super important number one here is a new
segment
called I was wrong I was wrong here's
what I was wrong about well there's
probably a bunch of things but here's
the big thing so I had a caller Kelly do
you know when that caller
was I don't have it off the top of my
head but if you'll give me a minute I
can find it okay um we had a caller who
called in and she was going through just
hell um she was really in a messy
situation and I asked her why she was
still staying in in what was a an
abusive marriage and she said there was
some pretty wild laws about divorce and
her estate that she had to stay in this
house and I told her I said that cannot
be right can't be right that's Madness
what if you end up getting killed like
right well I was wrong I was wrong and
um I was on the phone this morning with
my great friend Mike who's a brilliant
attorney in Texas and just talking
through um divorce law that if you don't
know divorce laws is state by state it's
not federal and you would think things
are very similar turns out across the
country they're not and I've been
working with somebody who is or walking
alongside somebody it's probably a
better way to say that um had a no fa
divorce very simple and it
took a magnitude of thousands of dollars
more than I thought it was going to and
it took probably 5x the time that I
thought it was going to take to get this
thing settled and so all that to say I
was wrong I was wrong um I'm going to
look for a great family law attorney and
see if we can have him on the show I get
a lot of questions about law and um kids
and breakups and divorce so I'm going to
see if I can find somebody who could
come on and tell me some of these things
that are going on in in different
jurisdictions across the country
different states and um some of the
things that individuals go through
through behind closed doors when it
comes to the divorce process so um Kelly
we'll put in the show notes we'll just
put in there but if you want to go back
and listen to the call I got some really
gnarly messages about how mean I was and
how stupid I am and all that's fine I
get that um and I was clearly wrong
about the uh divorce like I was wrong I
was wrong I did not know that some
states
um are run by morons so let's go out to
Columbia Tennessee and talk to Melissa
what's up Melissa hey Dr
what's up um just a lot of mess going on
uh oh tell me about
it so husband we've been together for
about seven years um got married last
year
um and about six months ago I entered an
affair with another man okay um and at
this point I am it was started out as
something fun I know that's stupid um
but it turned into something a lot more
emotional than I
expected and now at this point I just I
don't know what to do I mean I do know
what to do but I don't know what to do
at the same
time like I know cheating on my husband
is
wrong but at the same time I have really
deep feelings for this other man and I'm
in love with two men at the same time
and it's just very difficult
H what's Difficult about it for
you well it's because I love my husband
you don't hold on hold on you don't and
you have heard him so that that ship
sailed like what's hard about
it I just don't know what to do at this
point I I mean I I my husband doesn't
know um what's going on um the other
gentleman does know that I am
married um
and I don't want to leave my husband but
I don't want to break things off with
this other gentleman either so let me
let me put Let me give you another side
to this okay so okay number one I don't
think you love your husband I don't I
think you love the idea of the security
that seven plus years of of Quasi stable
relationship
brings I also think because well I'll
just leave it at that I also think deep
down you understand that you are with
somebody of so little
character that he doesn't mind blowing
up another
family so he can hook up with
somebody so I think you found yourself
in like a
pretty pretty uh
dicey moral dilemma and this isn't who
you want to be is it no it's not I mean
I consider my I I never done anything
like this in my entire life hold on hold
on I I don't care about that because you
are right you are right now you right
now and so that we can say those kind of
statements to make ourselves feel better
in the moment let's don't do that let's
don't try to like uh numb over this
moment okay it
sucks and so I don't see a way where all
of this doesn't end in Ash maybe it
does if you go back to your husband you
cut this off and you never talk to this
stranger again as long as you live
ever um and your husband chooses
to build something new with you because
your marriage as you know it is over
it's over completely burned to the
ground and if youall choose to build
something else
cool or you leave your husband of of one
year plus six years and
you make a life with this dude and
you're always going to know he's the
kind of guy that really doesn't
care he'll blow up somebody's family
just to get
his it's both hands right
yeah so like you called knowing probably
what you're going to do what are you
gonna
do
I I'm gonna tell my husband what's going
on and uh let him make the decision no
no no no no no he doesn't get to make
this call you got to be a grown
woman you made the decision to blow up
your house you made the decision to find
true true love finally with this dude
where'd y'all meet in the gym of course
is he a personal trainer he's not okay
um let me ask you this what what was it
about seven years with the guy that
became your
husband what about that
relationship it's been difficult um
we've had a lot of ups and downs I
suffer from mental illness I'm a
recovering drug addict okay so he's been
with me through a lot of stuff and I
felt like I owed my life to him for
pulling me out of everything I don't
feel like we're compatible in a lot of
ways because I like a lot of emotional
touch a lot of affirmation and I don't
feel like I get that have you ever been
really specific and clear with him about
what you need several times and he's
good for a couple of days and then he
just kind of falls back into Old Habits
okay why did you marry
him I felt like I owed it to him
honestly for everything that he went
through with
me um hospital stays rehabs that kind of
thing so I just felt like I owed it to
him to stay with him because he stayed
with me through a lot of crap that most
men wouldn't have
yeah and I think Rel ship and love out
of obligation eventually runs out of
gas yeah and sometimes what seems like
the the kindest thing to do can end up
being the
cruestv through Helen back with you and
he saw something in you seven years ago
that you couldn't see in yourself right
right and he and he took that trip and
instead of you having the harder
conversation saying honey I'm not going
to Mar you I'll always have a place for
you in my soul like like you walked
alongside me through some darkness and
um also I don't think we were meant to
be romantically involved for the rest of
our lives to build a life together um
both of those things can be
true and that might that might sound
mean but it's just being honest but
looking him in the eye and say I do
forever and then immediately finding
somebody new to hook up with that feels
more cruel
right what is it about your home that U
makes you feel like you're slowly
suffocating I it feels very controlling
in a way I my husband sees every dime
that I spend I have no access to any of
our financial
accounts I get an allowance of what I
can spend every week and he still like I
said he sees every dime I spend so he's
your dad he's not your
husband right go anywhere I mean yeah it
feels that way sometimes and I've told
him that you're not allowed to go
anywhere I not without telling him where
I'm
going so you're an abusive controlling
relationship it seems that way sometimes
yes
okay here's what I want you to do okay
um I want you to go find somebody to
talk to today before you talk to anybody
do you have
somebody I have a I have a I mean you
have a counselor in town you need a
neutral third party I do have a
counselor um it's my pastor at church
one of my pastors okay have you told
your pastor what's going on I have not
okay man this is hard here's why this is
hard oh boy I'm gonna get myself in
trouble
here
um all right I was just goingon to say
it
so I need you to sit down with
somebody who is not going to immediately
default to sending you back to an
abusive relationship
ship and there's some are there are some
extraordinary
brilliant trained
pastors
who understand that Fidelity in a
marriage is bigger than just who had sex
with
somebody but you can have Financial
infidelity and you can have um you can
stomp somebody's soul out and you're not
being a person of Fidelity in
marriage and my fear for you is that you
go tell a pastor and by the way I'm
telling you right now this other
relationship at the gym ends in a
supernova period and people on the
internet be like you don't know you
don't know I'm telling you right now
this ends bad okay so I would put that
one to bed and anybody who tells you
otherwise like no just go try it out and
see how it goes they're just that's just
YOLO nonsense okay
but if your pastor is somebody who will
listen to you and will hear you and will
hear you for the mess that your marriage
is right now and isn't instantly going
to say not to stay with knucklehead I
think you should cut that one off that's
just if you're my sister or my friend I
would say just be done with that you
what you're feeling is somebody treating
you on an equal playing field you're
feeling alive for the first time
probably post
sobriety and it feels like love it is
not it is two people that met at a gym
and they're hooking up the other side of
that is uh and by the way when you one
of you has security and one of you has
endless amounts of Freedom you can lay
together and dream and talk about the
future you can do all that stuff with no
strings attached because one of you is
anchored in and the other one's just at
C when you end up breaking up with uh if
your husband and you decide to break up
you're going to realize what a mess it
is what I'm nervous about is you go sit
with a pastor who's well-meaning and
says you have to end this relationship
at the gym fair I agree
and you've got to go back and be
subservient to a person who is abusive
to
you and that's where I would challenge
him here's the deal you may end up with
nobody at the end of this deal and I
don't know that that's the wrong move I
don't know that that's not the right
thing right
now being alone scares me honestly of
course does probably terrifies
you does being in an abusive
relationship terrify
you a little bit yeah just being with
somebody who cheat never h me so I've
never thought of it as abusive if
somebody won't let you be a person of
agency they treat you like their
daughter that is controlling now he
would probably tell me if I was talking
to him on the phone dude you don't know
how many nights I had to go find her in
an alley and the nights in rehab the
nights in the hospital we've created a
system that works to keep her alive is
that probably what he would tell
me
okay
yeah actually I'm gonna back out of all
my advice okay I'm not GNA tell you what
to do here I'm going to tell you
cheating on your husband's not right
never is it okay it's not
okay all right I'm going to tell you I
think you should go talk to your pastor
or your counselor and sit down and say
Here's what's happening here's where I
am and here's the things that my husband
does that makes me feel
unsafe and I also know that even though
this other person makes me feel alive
it's a facade it's not
real and that you don't know what to do
next okay
okay is that is that fair yes and do you
understand I'm not yelling at you I'm
not mad at you
I know I'm my heartaches for
you I can't even imagine the road you've
traveled
right probably not yeah I'll say this
I'm glad you're still
here if you are wrestling with mental
health
challenges please get under the care of
a trained licensed professional um I'm
going to give you three months free with
my friends at better help and stay on
the line we'll get you a code and you
can connect with a licensed counselor
licensed therapist there that can walk
alongside
you your husband's going to get to
decide if he wants to stay he doesn't
get to decide what you do you you're a
grown adult you get to decide what
happens
next I'm going ask to be a person of
good character and to admit where you've
gone sideways and to admit that you've
hurt
people and to also make a decision
moving forward that is in alignment with
your values with who you want to be your
character there is no way forward
without pain it's going to hurt it's
going to hurt multiple people it's going
to be a
mess and I promise you there's light on
the other side of it if you be a person
of character walking through it and if
you get people to walk with you you
can't do this by
yourself thank you for the call Melissa
let us know how it goes I can't wait to
hear about this one we'll be right back
hey good folks delone here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time those become healthy habits
they almost become automatic like
choosing to slow down and make time for
a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with my daily practice is hallow hallow
is the number one prayer app in the
world and they're giving you three free
months to get started that's three
months for free to prioritize your
mental and spiritual health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music through guided prayers
meditation and more and by the way
hallow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition or if you don't have a faith
tradition it's a great place to start
from scripture readings to prayers to
journaling Hall makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember Hall is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hall.com dealone today to start your
free trial just follow the simple
prompts at hall.com
dealone for 90 days
free all right we're back let's go out
to Witchita and talk to Elizabeth what's
up Elizabeth
yes what's
up hi um thank you for taking my call of
course
um um I was wondering how I can recover
from past trauma with my
son tell me what
happened um we my husband and I have I'm
sorry you're nous take your time take
your time you're good
um we've experienced a lot
of abusive sort of situations um
with her son um it got to the point
where um we have three other kids in our
home and
um we had to have
him removed from our home
um we so sorry no you're okay take your
time was it was it due to violence or
was it due to sexual predation like what
was it
violence is it adopted adopted son or
biological son he's my biological um I
had him with an abusive
ex-husband
um and then my husband adopted him a few
years
ago how old is
he he's 11
does he a war of the state
now yes yeah as far as I
know what was the benefit of and this is
me not there's no judgment here at all
I'm being curious I'm just interested in
the procedural like the mechanics what
was the benefit of waving your parental
rights signing him over to the state
versus putting him in a boy's home or a
children's home
um he's been in therapy and we've been
connected with multiple people um over
the last he he's been here since he was
four in Kansas and um where we're at
there just really isn't a whole lot um
and everything we were told by health
professionals and other people kind of
that were with us in our situation and
things
um everything that was said was that the
only option for those types of homes is
if he's in state custody so
um that was kind of a
decision obviously we did not take
lightly
sure I don't um I've got some friends
that um run wetstone boys ran to
Missouri in South
Missouri um but it's a place where
trouble boys go and they live there for
a year um I don't the the the purpose is
always
reunification but here's what I want
like so that's that's all I know I know
I know about boys ranches and I was on
the board at Texas Boys Ranch like so I
get how that system works this sounds
like I've never heard of the advice you
were given but um that doesn't mean it
was wrong it sounds like this may have
been a very extreme situation is that
fair
yeah
okay
okay so I'll tell you I'm so
sorry thank
you I'm sorry for the hell that's been
your home sorry for the hell that was
your abusive relationship I'm sorry for
the dreams y'all had the strains put on
your marriage I'm sorry for this little
boy who's clearly got some major major
struggles
yes
man I'm heartbroken for everybody I'm
heartbroken for this little boy I'm
heartbroken for y allall my goodness so
how can I help
you
guess sorry you're okay take your time
you're
okay otherwi how do I move on
mean
I don't think
it's I just don't
know I guess how
to help help myself help my family my
kids
um his brother's 10 years
old and his little sister's four um
while he was in the home and now she's
five even my other daughter's one
um are they missing him or is there
relief in the home what what how are the
kids
responding initially during all of it um
they wanted him gone because they
thought they thought we would not
survive
um it got really really bad um to the
point where we had no choice sure um so
here's the deal I don't um
I'm not here to second guess your choice
okay yeah my I'm here to sit with a
hurting
mama and I'm going to be honest I don't
know just step by step if your son had
passed away I would I would
know I would say here's what their next
steps are going to look like here's what
the next few years are going to look
like this one's a little bit different
because he's still out there
right
yeah and um you know the care that you
would have given him and you also
know this exceeded my ability to
help
right yeah I just feel bad for giving up
I
know
and I want you to feel good that your
other three kids are
safe
yeah so I don't see a super smooth
stepbystep transition from where you are
to this
new Kumbaya reality for a while it's
going to be really
hard yeah did you make this decision
hand inand with some great mental health
professionals and some
um people who are in your
corner um yes um it's just
outside of our family and the health
professionals like at our church and
things um and work it's extremely
difficult
to explain the situation and then don't
they don't get a they don't get a
vote yeah it's just hard when like my my
in-laws they um they're incredible
people they're the pastor of my
husband's um they're the pastor of
church that we go to
and um it's it's difficult for them
because and us too I mean when someone
asks oh how many children do you have or
how many grandchildren do you have um
it's so here's what here's it is here's
what people don't have to here's what
you don't have to go into detail about
custodial Arrangements you don't have to
go
into whose names on the whatever
list
you can say my oldest son if someone
says how many kids you have you can say
four I have one son who's in um a
home for boys who grew up with really
just overwhelming challenges as a young
kid wow my gosh what happened that's
just not something I like to talk
about and that's it they don't have to
know the C the custody Arrangements that
you signed over and all that stuff
and here's the
thing
um let's say he gets the treatment he
needs and there is a remarkable cure and
they find the right balance of
medication and work and therapy and all
of this stuff and he comes out at
18 and he'll be angry and frustrated and
you gave up on me and all that
stuff but if he's truly well and whole
when he's 23 24 25 he
may say
wow my mom was out of tools out of
options and when she couldn't sleep
knowing that I might go kill my brother
and sister in the middle of the
night she did what she had to
do
[Music]
[Applause]
right
and so here's what here's a couple
things I want you to do moveing forward
I want you to never ever say the word I
gave up on him because you
didn't
okay my guess is you probably went a
little bit too long is that
fair yeah yeah
probably yeah two don't try to wish this
away it's going to hurt for a while it's
going to hurt for a long
while
and all of this brought up that old crap
from your previous marriage
right yes I mean my ex-husband left me
but it's like we've been living with the
10 times version of him um for the
last eight years yeah
oh I want you
to make a regular practice of this
okay okay I want you to write a letter
to him maybe once a month maybe once a
week at the
beginning and just put it in a shoe
box okay and here's the fantasy okay and
by the way Pure Fantasy here the chances
of this happening are almost nil but
let's give it a
shot Let's Pretend he turns 25 one day
and is
functioning been through the system
and by then he's able to speak into
Alexa and AI finds you immediately and
he gets your
number and he calls and says mom I won't
have
coffee imagine you're able to slide
across the table a shoe box full of
letters and you're able to say even when
I couldn't take care of you even when I
couldn't hold you even when I couldn't
protect
you
I gave you to the
people that
could I never stopped loving you I never
stopped thinking about
you and if brother and sisters ask
where's brother where's Big
Brother say he had to move away so he
could get all the help and care that he
need because he's very very
sick and he is a kind of sick that he
can't be
here because it's not safe for him and
it's not safe for all of us but man we
sure do miss him don't we I miss him
too and can I tell you something really
important it's important for them to see
you cry and it's important for them to
see you
sad
yeah don't do that privately see me cry
a lot okay and tell him I miss brother I
wish he wasn't sick I wish is allowed to
be here but he's not allowed to be here
yeah okay and
okay I don't want you to gloss over this
don't you and your husband every single
week at the beginning of the week sit
down and say hey how can I love you this
week where are
you maybe he'll write him
letters and by the way in many ways this
might be a Fool's
errand and this might keep that wound
open for a long long time I just am of
the opinion that you can't close a wound
on a child like
this so I'd rather face that wound head
on then somehow pretend duct tape it
closed and pretend it's going to go away
because I don't think it is I think in
the back of your mind you're always
going to wonder what's Bubba
doing how is he today I wonder what his
day is like
today so I'd rather head into that storm
than just continue to push it away and
push it away and push it away also tell
you this that when families lose a
child when families go through this kind
of trauma it puts a unfathomable strain
on your
marriage so yall going to have to be
hyper intentional probably get some
marriage counseling probably connect
together this once a week how are you
how are you he might be ready to move on
in two weeks and you might be underwater
in two
weeks both of y'all are going to grieve
this differently and and there's going
to be days that you feel so relieved
he's gone and then you're going to
immediately feel like a bad mom both of
those are true both of those are okay
hold on that you're a bad mom is not
true it's not true at all but the
feelings are both going to be valid
okay oh my gosh I hate this for you I
hate this for you I hate this for you
I'm so
sorry if somebody listening has some
literature or some um I would love for
you to write in and
um uh you can email it to the show I'd
love to get some more information this
is one of the first times I've dealt
with State custody outside of some
really really traumatic mental health
disorders um but I'd love to read about
that um so if you have some literature
on that um you can send it to the show
at John dooney.com askk ask I would love
that
um Elizabeth you call anytime call
anytime we be walking alongside
you this episode is sponsored by better
help hey it's delone this time of year
there can be a lot of anxiety and a lot
of drama but it can also be great but
can also be a mix of everything right
especially when it comes to giving gifts
maybe your family makes super thoughtful
handmade things or they expect you to
spend a million dollars or maybe you
just like experiencing time together or
pick up random gift cards last minute
things like gift gift giving can make us
bananas so no matter how hectic it gets
especially around gift giving remember
to take care of yourself whether it's
going easier on yourself during tough
moments or having to say hey we don't
have enough money to buy all these gifts
or treating yourself to a Day of Silence
remember to give yourself some love this
holiday season and if things get too
heavy if thinking about dealing with
your family and all of the drug drama
gets to be too much give better help a
try better help is flexible because it's
online so it can fit into your busy
holiday schedule just fill out a short
questionnaire to get match with the
licensed therapist and you can switch
therapist at any time for no extra
charge in this season of Chaos in love
and sadness and all of it rolled up to
one give yourself what you need with
better help visit betterhelp.com dealone
today to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com all right we're back hey um
during that last break I got some I did
get some uh new information here so yes
there are some care services where young
people will go to get the care they need
and they can only go if they are Wards
of the state they can only get
enrollment into some of these places if
they're Awards of the state um and the
goal is often reunification so the state
might sign them back over to parents
when the kid is stable the family unit
is stable and all that so that's me
learning some new things um I knew that
that kids can get taken away if parents
sign them over if they don't want to
deal with it if there's like it
struggles with addiction I know all that
I know about the removal I did not know
that
um that there are only services
available to you if you if you're a
child's Award of the state I didn't know
that um so I'll continue to learn some
more on that and I'll bring it to you
and we've already we got a couple
experts here we can figure that out so
thank you'all all right let's go out to
Minnesota and talk to T money what's up
Tracy hi Dr John what's
happening uh just working um little my
WR
bet how we doing well um okay um so I
wrote Into the show um and the question
I wrote in is how do I tell my husband I
don't believe in him and I can't support
his dream
um I know that sounds terrible say
that's a hot
take hot
take so here's the backstory okay uh
we've been married for eight years we
have three kids ages
765 um prior to getting married um you
know my husband was very responsible
with money he didn't have any debt he
worked full-time he always had other
jobs Hobbies things he was working on he
was busy all the time um after a first
child was born he wanted to start his
own business and I supported him with
that he's very smart he's very skilled
he can do just about anything Plumbing
building working on engines basically
anything with his hand hold on hold on
this is awesome
because because he can build things
doesn't mean he can run a business
right yes yes yeah it's of like dude
education to run a business I am great
at barbecue I should open a barbecue
restaurant it's like those are two
different things oh boy okay so he
started like a mechanic shop or handyman
business or something a landscaping
business Landscaping all right and he
probably just got a like a spreadsheet
or a piece of paper and wrote down like
this many Lawns times this we're GNA be
rich and you were like
sweet yeah kind of yeah all right then
life happened all right so then what
yeah well he's a perfectionist so
everything always takes him 10 times
longer than it would somebody else if he
can even stay on task and finish it
struggles with anxiety okay and ADHD I
don't know anything about those two
things so continue you
don't um and about six years ago he
started drinking as a way to deal with
the anxiety and stress from his business
yeah um I guess in my opinion I feel
like he prioritizes work over family and
I've basically been a single mom this
entire
time um you know examples like being two
months pregnant with her second child
I've got a six-month-old at home and
I've got the flu and his response is
well I've got to go to work well you're
self-employed you can't take the day off
nope um um you know that's the
um um sacrifice you have to make when
you start a business if you want to
succeed is you just have to work all the
time 16 hour days seven days a
week um but currently um our situation
is is that we own a 15 acre fixer upper
hobby farm and there's a lot of debt
between that and his business um but now
he wants to turn it into a small
development not that he knows how to be
a developer um build and sell houses on
it and I don't feel like I can support
that um the appraisal came back that
it's basically worth twice what we paid
for it um and he thinks he can just take
out more loans to pay himself we're at
the Tipping Point where we can't barely
make the payments and his response is to
take more money out to pay the
payments all of this while he's still
drinking um you know he's alcoholic um
he can't get things done timely he can't
stay on task and he has more anxiety
because he's behind and so he drinks
more um accuses me not believing in him
but he's right I don't you know I don't
trust him I don't I just don't think
this is ever going to happen and I don't
know like how to have this conversation
with him without it sounding like an
ultimatum I think you're at
ultimatum I think you're I have I've
tried I've been there yeah but you
weren't
serious you already I don't know what my
ultimatum is you tell me
I mean I've I've threatened divorce and
haven't walked away I mean I mean that's
the nuclear
option you're y'all aren't addressing
the cordate issue here and I think the
core issue here is your husband's
clearly got some emotional health
challenges that he hasn't dealt with he
doesn't know how to be married to a
woman with three kids he doesn't know
how to parent three kids what he does
know how to do is incredible Landscaping
work when he shows
up and so he goes to the places where
he's
reinforced he's also probably talks to a
bunch of knuckleheaded dudes and watch
lots of YouTube about how just take your
land and Flip It and Roll It Roll it and
flip it and take a second mortgage and
then he lock that one and then triple
stamp a double stamp and he talked to a
couple of buddies and they're like yeah
dude
yeah and that's where he gets
reinforcement yep and then he come home
University do what I call it YouTube
University there you go it's always on
YouTube there you go which has some cool
things you can learn how to fix a thing
at your house and you can learn some
information but
man Michael Jordan didn't YouTube his uh
well he was he was not playing then I'm
trying to think uh
um um LeBron James doesn't YouTube his
nutrition stuff he hires a nutritionist
and he doesn't YouTube his exercise
program he has a personal trainer guys
who are successful don't YouTube The
Depths right they might YouTube how to
fix a door
handle all that doesn't matter he's your
husband's not on the phone with me right
now the question I have before you is
how long are you going to stay on this
ride
and there are places to get off before
divorce how many of these things have
you co-signed
on uh because of the state we live in I
have had to cosign on everything
okay even though none of it's in my
name what if you started today saying I
will never cosign another thing again
perod I have already said that
okay and if he signs your name does he
have power of attorney over over you no
okay if he signs your name then you tell
him I'm going to call the police and say
you fraudulently signed my name I'm
going to call the
bank has he done that no and he wouldn't
okay but this isn't about money and this
isn't about your hobby farm and this
isn't about
development this is about your
marriage I mean Hanging On by a by like
dancing on a razor blade MH what scares
you about having that conversation do
you think he's just going to walk out
the
door I don't do all confrontation I feel
like any time I try to confront him
about anything I lose the argument just
because he gets angry and he yells and I
basically just shut down okay so I just
don't feel like I can even have the
conversation we've tried some marriage
counseling it didn't really go anywhere
refuses to go back you know I've talked
to him about the drinking he says yes
it's a problem I'll get help when well
when this is done when that is done well
nothing's ever going to be done and I
know it's just a phrase he's using so
you have to decide okay what I've done
isn't
working I'm going to do something
different to protect me and my three
children because my husband has chosen
not to protect them or to protect
us I'm going to stop engaging in tit
fortat back and forth conversations
instead I'm going to write down and I'm
going to give him a copy and slide it
across the table after I read it to him
not before otherwise he won't listen to
you he'll just start reading and
say I can't live like this
anymore I feel incredibly
unsafe your addiction is out of control
your unwillingness to deal with your
emotional health is out of control when
he starts yelling say I'm not going to
engage in a back and forth not today we
can later but not today and tell them if
you yell I'm going to get up and
leave if you start going back and forth
I'm going to get up and leave will he at
least listen to you if you sat down and
had a conversation with
him I don't know anymore okay I mean I
also think he has more mental health
needs that I'm aware of you know and
sometimes I can't tell if it's that or
if it's the drinking I can't even tell
always when he's been drinking anymore
um the last conversation I tried to have
with him about something like this I
mean
he acted like he was psychotic I'm
punching walls um but he sore he hadn't
been drinking so I I don't know like I
don't know if there's something else
there but he won't go in and get
evaluated he says I'm not going to pay
somebody he feels like
it's the most ridiculous quote ever but
he he said it's like paying for sex to
go to a therapist I'm not going to pay
somebody for that
H just that's a strange correlation that
I would make but that's cool
so you've probably heard me say this on
the show but whenever I'm sitting down
and talking to someone like you I always
want to look at
Trends and this feels like over the last
five or six years this has just
continued to escalate in really um
unsafe
direction from hey I'm going to quit my
great job I'm gonna I'm gonna strike out
on my own to it's not working out quite
as I as much as I thought and I'm
incredible at my work but I'm not a
great boss especially of myself and I
don't have the discipline and then the
the nerves kick in and the anxiety kicks
in and the scatter brain kicks in and
trying to keep up with the call that
just came in on a piece of paper and I
can't find that paper but I'm supposed
to be somewhere all that stuff and the
one thing that shuts off those alarms is
alcohol to a few years later now he's
punching holes through
walls so my question for you is when and
where does this end what's your
line what's your or what
and more not more importantly but
equally importantly is what's that line
for your
kids
um gosh I just I don't know
anymore you're Outsourcing that to him
he doesn't get a vote right this second
I'm asking you if you were in a classro
at your local church and a man walked in
and started screaming and punching hole
Holes through walls what would you do
immediately
right if someone had taken your home
finances and made it such a precarious
situation that the chances of you having
a home to live in this time next
year are very
small what would you
do I've kind of already done it we we
are deated right now because of the
weird situation we got ourselves into
with this farm and we sold our house
last year me and the kids are living
with my mom and he's living out at the
farm by himself okay what I have told
him is that I will not move back in
there until you've gotten treatment so
I'm stuck kind of in this limbo point of
waiting for him to get treatment while
he's finishing this house out there for
us to live in maybe that I told him I'm
not going to move into if he doesn't get
treatment is he going to get
treatment he says he's going to when the
house is
done so his wife and his three kids
y'all just hang
on I'm GNA do whatever it is I want to
do whenever I want to do it y'all just
y'all just wait at your mom's
house yeah that's the current
situation and with the money as bad as
it is like I could try I talk to divorce
sler and I but I I just feel so stuck
with the money that if I were to divorce
him there's I'm I'm walking away
negative I mean we both
are I don't even know how I mean I'm
definitely not getting out of my mom's
house at that point then I don't think
you're getting out of your mom's house
for a long long
time am I guess is if I had to fast
forward a year you have three young kids
and you had a picture of what this was
going to be you married an amazing guy
who went to work and kicked butt and was
there for you and those younger kids as
they were starting to be born and for a
number of
reasons he has taken a totally different
path and so your picture of what was
going to be is now very very different
you never pictured yourself being a
single mom with three kids living back
with your mother you never pictured
yourself going back to work fulltime
which is what you're gonna have to do oh
I've been working full-time the whole
time okay all right good for you I'm the
one supports the family good for you I
have the health
insurance okay you have all of the Power
here you put food in his fridge you got
health insurance for
him you have all of it and your veiled
threats simply haven't
worked and I think there's a reckoning
of I got to deal with reality he will
not he he cares more about this project
than he does me and the kids behavior is
a language he cares more about trying to
figure out another scheme and another
scheme or let's just say he's really
sick and he simply won't go to the
doctor that's probably my biggest fear
like I feel like if we could get over
that
hurdle maybe some of the rest of it
would work out a little bit but you just
said have the conversation you said we
and that's not how it
works right he has to
decide and it sounds like he's willing
to lose his family before he goes and
gets the help he
needs does that sound
right well shoot he already has lost you
you already moved out yeah it seems that
way yeah he he talks differently but his
actions are that would he meet you in a
restaurant not at the house not at your
mother-in-law's house but just you two
at a restaurant
yeah and just ask him hey I need to I
need to know what the deal is or put it
this way you got 30 days to go or I'm
gonna have to make some different
decisions because I need to know whether
I need to get an apartment for these
kids or if we need to just make my mom's
house permanent for a while for a season
while I can save up some money I got to
figure out how bad the finances are and
we're going to divorce attorney's going
to have to do all that for
us or are you going to go to the doctor
within the next two
weeks and if he gets up and walks out of
the restaurant then you know
right and if you want to be extra
enabling you can grab uh get three names
of people who he could go see he could
call right
away
but he can consider counseling
prostitution all he wants but you get to
make the
call
okay what do you not like about this
something just doesn't sound right in
your soul is it that you just haven't
come to terms with the reality of the
situation or are you just holding out
cuz you love him and you want him to
come
back what is it it all feels like stuff
I kind of already done before like I've
I've tried having the conversation he's
had appointments for counseling for
treatment multiple times that I've
helped him set up and then the day comes
and he just does it go he says no I'm
okay I'm gonna I'll be I'll be sober and
then a month later then he's not um and
well then now he knows he doesn't have
to he knows that
now in fact when you call he's like oh
here we go I got to do the merry gound
thing again
MH and then he tells you all the right
things then you leave and he gets
another month or two to do whatever he
wants so it seems like the choices
before you are just to make peace with
this
cycle this is what it is or that
you make some very clear time and date
demand
for lack of better terms and he gets to
opt in or opt out I will file on this
date I've already moved out I've already
told you you have to quit being abusive
I already told you you have to stop
drinking I already told you you can't
take any more money
out you've already wrecked this family
and by the way if you sell the 15 Acres
if it's doubled in value and you drop
the price a little bit to get it sold
y'all can get your your financial
situation cleared
up he's going to go from 15 acres and
building his own house and going to
develop all this he's going to go to one
bedroom apartment but that's the life he
chose but that's really it looks like
that's the only two paths ahead of you
you've done all the leg work you've done
all this stuff you have to decide I'm
not leaving him I'm just
not so I'm just going to be here
plotting along giving him health
insurance doing my
life or you're going to be very clear
here's a piece of paper this is my this
is what it's going to take for you
this is how I know you want to stay
married to
me if not then the attorney's going to
call and we'll sell these assets and
we're going to split everything up and
then we're going to go our separate ways
because you clearly are more invested in
this life that you're fantasizing about
than you are about the kids and you are
about
[Music]
me I don't know many men who wouldn't
take their wife and their three kids
moving out as a huge alarm a five alarm
fire in their home
that's just me thanks for the call we'll
be right
[Music]
back hey what's up delone here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non-anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build build a more peaceful
nonanxious life get your copy today at
john.com
all right as we wrap up today's show man
Today's Show is it was it me today's
show just feels like walking through
like molasses yeah it was heavy and just
kind of like not a lot of yay at the end
yeah there's not a lot of great answers
to some of these challenges just hard
stuff a
man well as we wrap up today's show from
uh my neighbor over here in uh Tennessee
Chris
steton and I say neighbor like let's be
honest I live about 15 minutes
away you've never run into him at the at
the gr grocery store those 15 minutes
are might as well be 800
miles but it sounds cool to say my
neighbor he just put out a new record
and it's phenomenal Chris Stapleton
song's called trust and it goes like
this though we jump through hoops and
dance on wires walk on broken glass and
play with fire though were blindfolded
when we turn on the light I know
everything will be all right if you
trust in true love and you trust in time
if you trust in Forever trust this Heart
of Mine we can lose ourselves just like
lovers do if you trust in me like I
trust in you trust in me like I trust in
you love you guys we'll see you
soon